[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka spoiler man and
today we've just received leaks about
the extra post credit scene for
spider-man far from home if you've
already seen our prior breakdown of the
first post credits scene then you'll
know that the movie sets up a lot of
things for phase four of the MCU and it
looks like we finally had confirmation
of the second stinger which features a
huge cameo from a spider-man alumni
throughout this video I'll be breaking
down everything that apparently happens
in the scene as well as what it means
for the future this is full spoilers
ahead so if you don't want the movie
potentially ruined then I highly
recommend that you turn off now unlike
the other video this one also spoils
other elements of the film's plot and
whilst every leak like this should be
taken with a grain of salt this seems to
be backed up by a lot of high-profile
sources so it looks pretty legit so if
you want to avoid spoilers whatever it
takes then this is your last last last
chance to stop the video with that out
the way I just want to give a huge thank
you for clicking this I hope you enjoy
it now sit back relax and let's get into
part two of my breakdown of the
post-credits scene of spider-man far
from home okay so the first post credit
scene reportedly follows Mysterio
meeting with the chameleon scorpion
vulture and none other than Norman
Osborn at the recently renovated
Avengers tower which has been renamed
Oscorp this of course is massive massive
news for the spider-verse and in
addition to this the scene that follows
it apparently flashes out future films
to this leak for the final scene comes
from Marvel Studios spoilers on reddit
and was deleted by a mod but has been
recovered by another user and named best
bin bulletin the user says that in the
film it turns out that the multiverse is
fake and that Mysterio is actually a
disgruntled ex-employee of Tony Stark
who was fired for gross negligence
following the death of iron man Mysterio
has decided to use technology such as
Holograms drones and projectors to make
it seem like the world has been invaded
by evil forces that wiped out his earth
when Spiderman and it's this in the film
Mysterio comes up with a back-up plan to
frame the webhead and make it look like
he's the one causing all of the problems
the villain edits together a tape and
whilst we never see it in the main film
the rears its head in the end credits
scene it's basically like those deep
fakes on the internet that old people
believe because they haven't heard of
Photoshop and they think that Steve
Buscemi really likes wearing red dresses
all of a sudden and tying his hair up in
a nice nice little blonde style the tape
is shown and then we pull out to see
none other than Jay jonah Jameson
watching it the character is once again
and this is pretty mind-blowing played
by JK Simmons and he will be reprising
his role as the character and the
spider-man movies going forward other
evidence that backs up this post-credit
scene comes from a BuzzFeed reporter who
recently tweeted this still thinking
about spider-man far from home which
might be my faves by D film now Jake
Gyllenhaal is incredible a force and the
post-credits scene will make fans of the
original Tobey Maguire movie nostalgic
can't wait to see it again so all in all
it looks like the movie is really going
to set up the spider-man universe in an
interesting way that ties more heavily
into the comics than we probably ever
seen I'm very hype for this film right
now and with the release day getting
closer and closer I'm just getting more
and more excited obviously I'd love to
hear your thoughts on the news and if
you believe it or not comment below and
let me know and if you enjoyed this
video and haven't watched part one then
make sure you check it out after this it
breaks down the entire Norman Osborn
introduction scene and it's definitely
worth checking out if you want to know
more about the character and how they'll
be utilized in the MCU going forward
I'll leave that linked at the end so
make sure you give it a watch right
after this we've also just launched a
merch section on the channel so if you
want to support videos like this and get
something back from it then make sure
you click the link
boxes below this is a channel for people
who are super into superheroes so if
that's the kind of thing you like hit
subscribe thanks again for taking the
time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]